it's like a real-life horror story
nature's bloodsuckers vampire bats
they're headed north coming our way
this is like a swarm wow
i love tracking predators but these guys
are different they're the world's only
mammal that feeds solely on blood
that's freaky
if vampires are coming to america i
better get to know him and learn who's
on the menu
look at that oh my
to be honest with you to me this is like
a
rat's nest
need help just you
you're already done
i'm here in texas right in the middle of
america's back country
i get it done wrong it's the last time
you put it on right
i'll check you okay
but man i don't know anything about bats
or caves or caving
boys are comfortable
so i've never really done anything like
this is completely a new adventure for
me and it's
like any new adventure it's exciting
and a little nerve-wracking at the same
time
and tight asses yeah you know you don't
want to make a mistake when it comes to
this stuff do you
you don't
so here we go i'm about to drop into a
cave that's never been filmed before is
that the last guy didn't tie in
if i really want to get to know vampire
bats i've got to get to the bottom of
this blood curdling story
the center for disease control has
confirmed a case of rabies in a migrant
farm worker the first reported death
from a vampire bat rabies virus in the
united states
research suggests that the range of
these bats might be expanding as a
result of climate change this would lead
to increased bad exposures to both
humans and animals in the u.s
into the bat layer i go to the bat layer
be careful man
i know nothing about underground so this
is uh
very exciting for me and a little bit
a little worry some dude
all my life i've studied predators bears
lions and wolves and i've defended them
they have really important jobs in the
environment and sometimes they just get
a bad rap but this is certainly a
different kind of predator this is the
only mammal that lives on 100
blood
all right jim okay let me know when
you're clear
all right i'm clear
[Music]
man this is pretty awesome
[Music]
i'll be hanging with jim kennedy a bat
biologist who knows this cave better
than anyone
i take a lot of people caving and they
just freak out because of the
claustrophobia and the darkness and so
on
i hope casey's not like that
i'm a little bigger boy than you are jim
i'm older than you man it makes us even
all right
boys like putting on a
pair of pants from high school
i'll notice the odor
yeah it's getting much more pungent as
we're getting closer to the bat roost
very pungent
okay
we should be seeing bats by now when
we're not
i'm confused we're seeing a lot of bat
sign we're seeing big piles of
relatively fresh guano
but no bats
it's a mystery i don't know what the
heck is going on here because this time
of year we usually have a couple of
thousand bats in this area
now most people would be glad to not run
into nature's only flying mammal
let's face it bats are kind of freaky
but surprise surprise here in texas
things are a little different
downtown austin it's a party especially
during this annual celebration
fat fest
what do you think about bats
they're pretty cool i love bats they're
part of boston you know i think bats are
cool yes
right now i'm walking on the congress
avenue bridge this place is going crazy
you know what they're going crazy for
what's right below me under this bridge
millions of mexican retail bats
about 30 years ago the bridge was
reconstructed and the designers didn't
realize they were creating perfect
little niches crevices under the bridge
and the bats started moving in
the city of austin loves their bats
but they've got something coming their
way
vampire pass
well how do you feel about vampire bats
you know there's a rumor that they could
be moving north and they might be right
here in austin i think i would want to
run away screaming
they drink
i think
i don't know i don't know i might be a
little bit concerned
when the bridge bats first moved in
everybody panicked are they gonna bite
me do they all have rabies
but then the folks learn these bats are
cool they eat 10 000 pounds of insects
every night and they look pretty awesome
when they fly out to supper
right now there's thousands of people up
on top of the bridge waiting for the
emergence of the banks what are the bats
doing well i had to find out so i came
down here with this thermal camera
and
that's actually the body heat of these
bats sitting there waiting for just the
right time to emerge and head that way
to go eat a bunch of bugs
and then suddenly
without any warning
i can't believe the number of bats
exploded out from underneath the bridge
right in the heart of the city
it's incredible
and the crowd is loving it
[Music]
but fear of predators can destroy a love
affair
i've seen it happen with wolves and
bears
and i need to find out if a vampire bat
invasion would crash this party
we're gonna go track down these animals
try to find out where they are but this
is a very different way than i'm used to
tracking
so what do you think do you think we
should keep looking
well i'd like to
vampire bats haven't arrived in this
cave yet but there's something wrong
because the local bats they're not here
either
why are we going down that hole it
doesn't even look like a bat could fit
down that hole bats go through the air
down into the hole we go
to get the packs as soon as i'm stable
man
this is crazy
[Music]
all right
let's suck it in
oh
man
i don't know what am i doing this for
ah
okay that just like
is me have to like suck in my areas to
get through that hole
oh my god i'm not sure
i'll work this
oh man i'm like stuck on this
oh man
hey jim
yeah
i got myself in a bit of a spot here i'm
definitely wedged
here i am
40 meters beneath earth's surface
and something that is just as wide as me
i don't know how i got myself into this
situation
you don't even have to be claustrophobic
for this to freak you out
i mean this is
like a
tomb
like i'm sitting in a coffin
any uh any i i'm trying but my arm's
kind of
pinned here and i got a
oh
a little bit farther in there
that that's freaky
all right i'm gonna keep coming
so we make it all the way down there
and there's nothing
there's usually a pretty good bunch of
bats in this room
i i don't know what's going on with the
bats here we know we're getting a lot of
drought in this part of the country um
things are getting warmer
so jim decides he's going to stick up
one of his data loggers
these little devices that record
conditions like temperature and humidity
so if the conditions are changing here
in the cave
potentially even getting warmer
could this be a future home to vampire
bats well
i guess it's possible well you know we
really don't know
but uh we're running out of light we're
running out of time here now so we need
to keep moving man okay i'm after you
man
oh
look at all those
look at them
just rafting off the ceiling look big
gums
it's like daddy long leg crazy central
i'll tell you what being in here in the
dark
having all these bugs falling from the
ceiling
it is a little freaky
if you have arachnophobia and
claustrophobia and you're in this cave
right now you're running as fast as you
can back to the entrance because you've
just entered a nightmare
stop stop
look at this
look at all the bones skulls and
skeletal material
so this is a baby bat it's held down it
was a baby bath
i mean literally we're sitting in a bat
graveyard
but this is kind of worries me to see
this many
fresh skeletons
so i'm just sitting there looking at
these bad skeletons and then i see
something walking across the floor
look at that it's still alive it's just
it is
i wonder if it's injured
he doesn't look like he's doing too good
no he shouldn't be on the ground like
this especially in the middle of the day
you start to think why are these
skeletons on the floor why is this bat
sick is there rabies in the cave are
there bad gasses
then you start to wonder if all of this
is present what's gonna happen to us
all right it's time to move all kinds of
things crawling in my throat right now
up my nostrils in my eyes
sitting in this bat graveyard we're
literally having the fate of some of
these bats getting eaten alive by
insects there's bugs all over me we just
gotta keep going
man
so we're climbing up the hill and jim's
like i hear something listen do you hear
that yeah yeah yeah
you have a really high-pitched squeaky
check this out they're everywhere we
found the colony of bats this chamber is
alive with bats right now
i'm in the middle of a back hurricane
literally it's a vortex of bats flying
around making all kinds of awesome noise
i've seen a few bats in my time but a
swarm that big that many bats yeah
unbelievable i'd say there's at least 10
000 bats in this one room all right i'm
gonna try to catch one now okay
i got one you got one in there yeah
right there we got one hanging on right
here too check it out here he got me
so you got
look it's another free tail like we saw
look at we found the entire colony this
guy is alive happy fighting back
all his buddies are flying all around us
i can feel the air coming off their
wings it's awesome to be around this
many bass at one time
and with my heat sensing camera
this place looks like a cloud of
fireflies
[Music]
i can see the heat signature of every
bat out here
to be in the batcave to be right where
they live
without swirling around your head is
about the ultimate bad experience
[Music]
wow
[Music]
i'm really starting to get it i can see
why texans love their bats
but how would they feel if these bats
were vampires
and the truth is i don't even know how i
would feel i don't know anything about
vampire bats
[Music]
if i've ever seen a bat that looks like
dracula it's this guy so this has gotta
be a vampire bat people have confused
this bat with a vampire bat and its
scientific name is tyropus vampyrus but
it is a fruit eater i'm with bat expert
rob beast aka the bat daddy for a little
bat 101
i feel like i'm upside down when i'm in
here
right
so this is a straw colored flying box
yeah you can see the flying fox in there
look definitely like little fox
almost a quarter of all mammal species
are bats
they live just about everywhere and eat
all kinds of things insects nectar fruit
and blood
so these little fruit eaters are awesome
but no i'm here to see the blood eaters
here we go
oh
well look at these little guys
here are these little dudes like this
big
who would have thought a vampire bats
gonna be this little thing
now hanging out with the fruit bass was
awesome but there's no way to go in here
oh yeah we can go in there absolutely
we're going in there
here we go they're really fast look and
they're like someone they're running
around the ground yeah
they're not just flying around they're
landing and creeping and crawling
they're little creepy crawler teams
everywhere
look how fast they are
these guys are cool
and look at the little teeth these guys
have they look hungry
[Music]
most bats take off from a hanging
position but vampires
they're like little superhero bats
they crawl on the ground
they sneak up on their prey and then
they hop up on their victim
[Music]
a freaky level zone to be in
hanging out in a vampire cage
with a bunch of hungry vampire bats and
they're all looking at me
what are you guys looking at
okay i get it these guys are cool
especially one-on-one
but am i ready to be swarmed by wild
vampires in mexico
for my final test in texas
jim takes me to the largest colony of
bats on earth
super fast snake
[Music]
he's really pretty it's a good size one
too yeah
coach rips are super predators they
don't have venom
just insane speed and a powerful bite
so we we often find these guys around
cave entrances casey because they'll
actually do that all right gotta be very
careful letting this guy go hundreds of
sharp little teeth and an infection if
he bites me so i'm gonna let go of his
tail and his head blast here we go
i'll tell you chasing a snake that fast
with flip-flops
not recommended
tonight i'm following the co-trip to one
of america's biggest feeding frenzies
fracking bat cave is the world's largest
bat roost there are millions and
millions of bats here
i know they're in there
i can hear them
and then
if you didn't like best if you were
afraid of ask it would be an absolute
nightmare this is like you've seen that
movie alfred hitchcock the birds and
this is like a swarm
every night something like 20 million
free-tailed bats leave the cave
and this is the most
mammals
biggest congregation of mammals in the
entire world right here i'm just one of
the mammals one in a million
i always like to think of that about
myself
this is absolutely amazing i'm getting
like i was not raining now so i'm
assuming that that's something else yeah
we always tell people when if you're
looking up and off keep your mouth
closed yeah i mean i've got it already
all right
got it
[Music]
when the wind blows they just start
crashing
mostly that's this year's jump they're
not really strong flyers yet
so that's what the predators are waiting
for they're waiting for these bats to
crash land and then they're just going
to go there right
when a bat gets snagged it's prey
here come the coach whips well there's a
big coach right here
there's one over there more coming down
the hill here's another one
right here got he's got a bat got it
there's a coach whip right here where
the batman's mountain right here right
next to us
how cool is that right there
coach whip just nailed it
we have bats on the boom yeah there's
bats everywhere look at this right here
they're crashing
okay one in the bushes right here
there he goes look at him
there he goes
there's a big one right here coming
right straight at us let's go over it
right here got one he just got one right
there
[Music]
what's crazy is the bats that survive
the coach trips become predators too
they'll travel hundreds of miles tonight
feasting on 200 tons of bugs before they
return
free pest control
a major bonus for texas
and this will go on for hours
hours
really this is really cool
i think i'm finally ready to face a mob
of vampires see what would really happen
if they show up in texas
it's time to go to the source
off to the jungles of mexico
[Music]
my adventure south of the border starts
here in the meat market
and i'm looking for an old friend
hey welcome to chi office man scotty is
a veteran cave explorer he spent a ton
of time down here
and i know with scotty there's never a
dull moment
one of the main reasons why we met at
the market was to try one of the local
culinary
delights if you have an appetite
this looks awesome i can see already
he's got something up his sleeve and
what is this oh this is uh a little
surprise for you it's called moronga
moronga and i dig right in i love you
know authentic
indigenous foods and i take a big bite
and he then tells me
not chicken
well moronga is blood sausage
but i'm like blood sausage so this is
actually made of blood absolutely like
there's no it's meat here no they
actually pour the blood into the
intestines
so this is an intestine yes sir
yes this is an intestine yes filled with
blood and voila
the same stuff that's in my mouth right
now
i have to admit that i must have a bit
of vampire in me because
you're enjoying it already good
i know this is scotty's idea of some
kind of joke getting me to eat blood
like some vampire
but i'm here to hang with some real
vampire bats scotty knows just the place
a hidden cave he calls the torture
chamber
vampire bats by the thousands and
they're sweeping at your face
you're wading through bat guano that's
covered in blood and maggots
i had to go to this place
the torso chamber it's an amazing thing
it's been like
literally
haunting me
since the last time i saw you there's
thousands of bats in this place and it's
something that most people would
probably think was a nightmare like me
i thought it was a nightmare that's why
we call it the torture chamber
i don't mind caves i don't get
claustrophobic i can go in and out of
caves all day long but if they're filled
with bats and insects and
you know all kinds of things like that
that is not one of my comfort zones this
is something that's not on the map
absolutely not it's all up here they're
all in scotty's head yeah that's the
scary part scotty's one of these guys
like like a lot of my friends in high
school you know you're gonna have a
great time when you hang out with them
there's always a chance you're gonna end
up in jail
[Music]
i can honestly say i'm not totally
comfortable with
thousands of bats flying all around me
um
so if we find this cave i'll be
a little apprehensive to get back in
there
and notice right away scotty's not
looking at a map he's not looking at
some gps this guy doesn't know where the
heck he's going
i've learned to understand that my
memory is not that great i mean i look
around here it's like
jungle tree
plant
jungle
not much uh for
landmarks well it's one of the trickiest
parts is gonna be to find this cave you
know i think it was
heck almost 20 years ago that i was in
there
he's just gonna
recollect something that happened 20
years ago
great
[Music]
what's that big cool tree right there
that is actually a savory tree right
there that's an incredibly majestic tree
right there that's the sacred tree to
the mayan indians
this is starting to unfold this whole
trek it's like go to the save a tree and
then take 15 paces and when you see the
howler monkey then you get in the river
and you go down until you see the
crocodile then when you see the
crocodile then a few steps past that
around the corner there might be a mayan
ruin i could see
we're just kind of winging it
here we go
casey the ruins of yakshitlan we're
finally in the area we're getting close
okay
hopefully we can find the torture
chamber with a little help from the
locals here okay yeah go get some advice
i'm hoping that at least one of the
custodians that works at the ruins will
help refresh my memory of where this
cave is
okay i'm just now coming into
the very first part of yakshalan and
it's
what they call the labyrinth it is dark
basically amazing here
[Music]
oh yeah right here look
oh
at
this
cool
now that
is what rob showed me that's a jamaican
fruit bat
oh there we go all right
right
whoa i mean they got some serious jaw
pressure
the jamaican fruit bat has this crazy
leaf-shaped nose that sticks out of the
front of its face
every time it moves like that it's echo
located
but i'm looking for a very different
type of nose
vampire bat has this flat almost
pig-like nose
[Music]
and then it has this cleft it's got this
little groove that's tongue comes down
that uses it to lap up blood
around its mouth it has heat sensing
organs it'll literally go right up to
the skin feeling where
the blood is closest to the edge
[Music]
they have the biggest brains
of all the bats so if you caught a
vampire bat it's gonna be wild at first
it's gonna be hissing it's gonna be
trying to get away then it goes dasa but
it waits
it waits for you just to slightly open
your hand and then it's going to be out
of there and gone you have to be
thinking this animal knows what's going
on
get after it
wow
okay
we're getting somewhere
yeah right
feels like it
off the boat on the river now we are
officially
in the middle of the jungle
hopefully we can find this cave
there's vampire bats
following the right make sure you're
going the right way
not totally sure but
we'll get there just have to find our
right direction
you can spend a lot of time hacking
through the jungle and go
two 300 feet in the wrong direction wow
it's thick it is thick i can't tell
which way's up down and i don't think he
can either
you're down in the thicket of it all you
can't see really anything
and you kind of gotta go with your sixth
sense to find this
somewhat of a needle in a haystack
and again i'm starting to see that that
face of doubt
on scotty
sounds like we're getting closer to the
river
we going the right way no we're going
the right way
look i hear the stream
yeah yeah you hear that i mean
well as there's a stream coming out of
the entrance
and we got it made once we can follow
that stream up into the cave entrance
jackpot
game on
yeah there's the entrance
all right
and i i just feel like
and the quest for the vampires is on
i am so elated i'm so excited but then
he starts pulling out respirators what's
this for well there's a lot more in this
cave than uh just vampires that uh can
kill you there's all kinds of mites um
you know obviously the guano
[Applause]
you're excited to to go into the cave
you're a little apprehensive of what it
might bring and in one aspect i'm
thinking well maybe the bats are gone
maybe it won't be so bad yeah
this is insane
if i didn't have this respiratory
nose or my mouth right now they're all
over my eyes
i mean it was almost unbearable
this
is absolute torture
[Music]
it's unbelievable these formations
coming out trickles of water which is
gorgeous like it seemed like we were in
a fantasy land as we walked further into
this cave
i mean what
one man's torture chamber is another
man's paradise
and then in the distance
far into the darkness i can hear what
sounds like the roar
this is no roar of a rapid this is a
roar of a
[Music]
this is not like any cave i've been in
bats usually try to avoid you it almost
seems like they're coming after us
they're going right by me i'm ducking
and diving i look over at scotty he
looks terrified
how are you feeling right now scotty wow
[Music]
looks like there's a
bunch of vamps in here
[Music]
just looking at the size here i think
there's way more
than just vampires in
here oh look right here
a little insect eating
bad right there on the
another
ground
another path that eats insects look at
this other guy he's called a ghost face
back that is so cool
man there's a lot of them in here
[Music]
trying to find some vampires here
let's keep looking let's just get a
closer look at these bats and then see
if we can find where the vampires are
we've got nectar eaters we've got fruit
eaters we've got sex divorce
all these bats are incredibly important
to the jungles it's just above the cave
pollination sea dispersal and pest
control vampires in here it's really
hard to tell with all these bats flying
around
i mean in all of this bat chaos i
realize there's really no way i'll be
able to identify vampires even if they
are here
[Music]
it's the ultimate back team right here
seriously this might be the coolest cave
ever been
[Music]
i mean this was a quite a bad experience
but this is not where my vampire search
ends
it's time to change my strategy
i know back home when i track wolves i
go to the elk if i want to find mountain
lions i go to the deer
if i want to find vampire bats i must go
to the blood
this total evidence right there on the
neck look at that
there's vampires on this branch
[Music]
known for its livestock and it's cattle
and uh there's a lot of ranches around
here who are having a ton of issues
with these bats actually
weakening the hurt
[Music]
oh yeah right there
and if you look right up by the neck
there carmen's saying that yeah look
right here
[Music]
you can see
the coagulated blood where it was
pouring out from last night
i'm looking at all these cows and it's
shocking because out there in the wild
vampire bats are actually pretty rare
with all this cattle vampires suddenly
have a huge new food source i mean one
day could this be a cattle ranch in
texas
and there's no other culprit other than
a vampire bat that would cause wounds
like that
so
definite evidence there's vampires on
this ranch
[Music]
anna a bat biologist is investigating
the vampire's preying on these cows
so i'm helping her set up these mist
nets to capture the culprits as they
head in for the blood
and you put it all the way down on the
ground because
vampires will go
crawl along
[Music]
so we're sitting there in the dark and
then suddenly we hear
[Music]
i know
and i was sure when we got there it was
gonna be a vampire bat
oh yeah got a bat we got a bath
so this is not a vampire this little guy
is actually known as a mustache bag look
at those teeth
i mean this little guy is a predator
compared to the size of its body it's
got teeth just as big as a mountain lion
or a wolf
again hear that sound right over there
it's gotta be a vampire bat this time
so this is a jamaican fruit eating bath
look at that little guy yeah he's just
biting very very hard
here we go again i've caught a mustache
bat i've caught a jamaican fruit eater
not a sign of a vampire
[Music]
then i hear something that gets my heart
pumping
i hear something caught in the bottom of
the net
i look down there on the ground
i see something caught in the net with a
face that i recognize
[Music]
vampire
the vampires are here this guy was going
over the cows got caught in the mismat
this is what i'm looking for a wild
vampire back
here we are face to face finally uh it's
all the places i've gone
this little guy right here this is so
cool
here's another one
there's vampires everywhere
these vampire bats are crawling doing
that very creepy distinctive behavior
that only vampire bats do
you know when you think about vampires
everybody's thinking they're going to
have these big extended canines that's
what's going to do all the damage but
the truth is they have these incisors
right in the front these teeth
that are very very sharp and that's what
they're using to get the blood out and
he's actually using those same incisors
to cut this net right in half like no
problem
so the situation's perfect i'm here the
vampires are here and the cows are here
i'm gonna use my thermal binoculars to
see if i can actually witness
wild vampire bats feeding on blood
[Music]
i just saw a batman on the back of the
cows
[Music]
and it is so insane how many bats are
around is something
that i imagined but this is way more
intense
this is the stuff that horror movies are
made up right here
oh my god
[Music]
there's bats on there just feeding for
minutes and the cows are just laying
there chewing their cud as the bats are
lapping their blood
the bat's teeth are so sharp that its
victim barely feels its bite
and an anticoagulant in the bat saliva
makes the blood just streaming from the
wound
i can see that white hot blood leak out
ooze out and a little vampire bat just
sitting there lapping it up and as the
blood runs down the cow it cools into a
dark black and drips to the ground
this is ridiculous
[Music]
i'm really seeing
this whole thing coming together and as
the climate warms up
these bats will have the opportunity to
to move north and there's plenty of
cattle in the united states so
this vampire action will be coming to
america
[Music]
there's something i want to know
something that might be a little crazy
am i also on the menu
[Music]
there are vampire bats everywhere
they're swarming all over the cows
i'm gonna lay down right next to them
maybe look him over and see me this
might be
the craziest thing i've ever done
but then right as i'm lying down
my headlamp hits this little cap right
next to me
and i can't believe what i see
i mean that is
absolute
look at that oh my god
do you have to get that
there's blood running out of it
everywhere it's just caked all over it
that is insane thank you for a calf
so now i'm starting to second guess my
decision to lie down
maybe not the smartest thing i've ever
done in my life
but this is going to be a really cool
experiment
give a little something to bite in i
would like
so i've got my arms exposed my feet
exposed my face exposed and i lay down
all i've got to do is just sit really
still
i can hear
the bats flying right over my head
they're checking me out i can feel the
wind off their wings
once in a while the little batch would
be sucking the blood under this look up
and catch my eyes
and i think he's thinking
i'm for dessert
i'm watching these bats just gorge
themselves
wow look at them they're just drinking
that stuff like crazy
they drink almost half their body weight
in blood in a single feeding
before cattle arrive vampires didn't
know when their next meal was coming
so they've learned how to do something
really crazy
when a feasting bat returns to the
colony it regurgitates its meal for the
other bass to consume
it's an amazing and bloody survival
strategy
something you can appreciate unless
you're about to become dinner
[Music]
it's pretty hard just to lay there and
wonder
is a vampire bat gonna bite me or not
they still burn around you know
[Music]
i've been laying here quite some time
tonight
the vampire bats
have only
been feeding on the cows in fact once a
vampire gets the taste of individuals
blood
it likes to come back to that individual
cow
night after night
and it looks like the flavor of the
night is that more calf right there
this is really hard to watch
but these baths are just doing what
predators do
we gave the vampires a blood buffet and
then we turned up the planet's
thermostat and now nature is just taking
advantage
it's kind of freaky just lay there and
sacrifice like hoping a vampire will
ever bite you i'm wondering what it's
going to feel like but
tonight the vampires like cow blood so i
walk away
without a bite
this is the first of me laying myself
out as prey for the predator that i'm
tracking
definitely freaky
but maybe one of the coolest things i've
ever tried
but now whether they're blood suckers or
bug eaters i think bats are one of the
coolest predators on the planet
that experience
affected me in a lot of ways
i think that moment has changed me
forever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you